may we start
uh with a brief reading from the
coddling of the american mind
excellent all right so this book for
those of you who don't know
uh by greg lukianov and jonathan height
the cuddling of the american mind how
good intentions and bad ideas are
setting up a generation for failure
was published two years ago this week uh
it's
an extraordinary book it was based on an
article in the atlantic of the same name
i believe
from a couple of years prior and um
pamela pereski who was their senior
researcher on the book
uh approached us along with jonathan
height just as evergreen was blowing up
to talk to us about what
what we were seeing there and so we were
we were privileged to be able to see
this book as it was
as it was emerging and excuse me
um i just want to briefly summarize a
couple of their
main points and then read a little bit
from it
so they start by naming three what they
call three great untruths
which are what doesn't kill you makes
you weaker what they call the untruth of
fragility
always trust your feelings what they
call the untruth of emotional reasoning
and life is a battle between good people
and bad people
the untruth of us versus them this of
course is
akin to what we've been calling the
battle between the star belly snatches
and the sneetches without
that was cat chaos in the background if
you guys could hear that
so in this final section of the book
they
refer to those truths and they say okay
but um
what what may explain them and they say
we present six interacting explanatory
threads
rising political polarization and
cross-party animosity
rising levels of teen anxiety and
depression changes in parenting
practices
the decline of free play the growth of
campus bureaucracy
and a rising passion for justice in
response to major national events
combined with changing ideas about what
justice requires
so all of those of course are um if
anything more relevant more apropos
today than when they publish the book
and you know they of course books aren't
written the day they're published so
when they were writing this when they
were first seeing some of these things
emerging on campus in particular and
they they point to 2014 as a sort of a
pivot point
um and then they wrote their uh article
in the atlantic
i can't remember if it was 15 or 16 and
then this was published two years ago
and here we are today
with you know such extreme examples of
polarization on the streets and
and you know all of these things but
also to to look to their last one
uh changing ideas about what justice
requires
right so here uh they have earlier in
the book
on page 75 76
they describe a scene from
uh september 6 2017 so this would have
been
after charlottesville within a month or
so of charlottesville i think
and i just want to read to you the
description of what happened here
appeals to common humanity still work
just as well today as when dr king made
them
on september 16 2017 on the national
mall in washington dc a group of trump
supporters organized a rally they called
the mother of all rallies patriot
unification gathering
counter protesters from black lives
matter showed up and shouted at the
trump supporters
the trump supporters shouted back
someone on stage told the trump
supporters to pay no attention to the
counter protesters
they don't exist he said hawke newsom
the leader of the blm counter
protesters later said that he expected
to quote stand there with his fist in
the air in a very militant way and to
exchange insults
tensions mounted and onlookers recorded
video of the potentially explosive
situation
then the trump rally organizer who goes
by the name tommy gunn took the stage
it's about freedom of speech he said in
an unexpected move he invited newsome
and other blm supporters onto the stage
we're going to give you two minutes of
our platform to put your message out
gunn told newsom
now whether they disagree or agree with
your message is irrelevant it's the fact
that you have the right to have the
message
newsom took the stage i'm an american he
began
and the crowd cheered and the beauty of
america is that when you see something
broke in your country you can mobilize
to fix it
but then as he spoke about a black man
being killed by police the crowd began
to turn on him
they booed shut up that was a criminal a
woman shouted
newsome explained we are not anti-cop
yes you are people shouted
we're anti-bad cop knew some insisted he
still seemed to be losing them
we don't want handouts he told the crowd
we don't want anything that is yours
we want our god-given right to freedom
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
now they were coming back around people
cheered someone in the crowd shouted all
lives matter
which is usually intended as a rebuke to
those who say that black lives matter
but newsom responded in the tradition of
paulie murray by drawing a larger circle
around everyone in the crowd
you're right my brother you're right you
are so right all lives matter right
but when a black live is lost we get no
justice that is why we say black lives
matter
if we really want to make america great
we do it together
the crowd cheered and chanted usa usa
in an instant the two groups were no
longer us and them
their ideological differences remained
but within that larger circle around
them their enmity melted away
and at least for a short while they
interrupted his fellow human beings and
fellow americans
it kind of restored my faith newsom said
when interviewed afterwards
two sides that never listened to each
other actually made progress today
one of the leaders of bikers for trump
came up to newsom afterward and shook
his hand
the two men talked and then posed for a
photo together with newsome holding the
other man's young son
cradled in his arm
so that has many of the elements that we
recognize from today's protests and
riots and yet
has a a very different tenor in part
because
members of both sides the would-be
leaders of both sides are willing to say
you have a space to talk here and we are
going to listen we don't have to agree
uh people on our side may yell at you uh
but
we're we're going to listen i want to
point out you
read that description from coddling of
the american mind
known informally in some circles as
coddling the cuddling
about hawk newsome who had gone to the
the trump rally as a
blm supporter
and had had that very extraordinary
interaction
now if you haven't seen the video of
that interaction you should look it up
just look up hawk news some
i'm sure it's on youtube it'll be one of
the early results
it's a an absolutely beautiful thing
and i must say it represents a
possibility that hovers
everywhere right people are
in general decent and if you are willing
to give them a chance
they will very frequently give you a
chance and you can cross these bridges
and you and i have been doing this
it's extremely rewarding there's no
reason you shouldn't do it
however the tragedy of that
particular case is that
um hawk demonstrates on video and many
people saw it i mean it was like the
kind of stuff that brings you to tears
in an environment like this
um that hawk obviously has that capacity
within him
as did the leader of the of the
pro-trump movement but i don't remember
his name absolutely
um however if you will check in
with hawke more recently he is no longer
of this mindset
and i think that this uh represents a
um really a catastrophe because
what do we see well so um you should
look up
a podcast that john wood jr who
if you're not familiar with him but that
sounds familiar you may remember him
from the black intellectual round table
that we did on darkhorse
so john wood jr is
an ambassador for the organization
braver angels and the braver angels
podcast
uh john had bob woodson the friend of
ours
uh on with who was bob woodson
uh who marched with king in the 60s he's
a he's an original
civil rights uh activist from the 60s
he's an original civil rights activist
and
this is interesting he marched with king
he was originally
very much on board and then he watched
the movement change and he
parted ways with it and he's been um
doing amazing work
ever since so really high quality work
that has
um saved a great many people uh
so but definitely speaking now from from
the right side of the aisle from the
aisle not the correct side the right
side so he's a republican now
he's he is but um at some level
he is on the personal responsibility
side of things on the other hand
personal responsibility demonstrably
works and he
has been absolutely tireless about this
and the um positive effect is undeniable
so
he speaks with a great deal of
credibility um
hawk newsome was having none of it on
this podcast
so john wood jr is leading a
conversation between bob woodson and
hawk newsome okay
yeah and basically hawk newsome
effectively repudiates his openness
that he displayed in the interaction
with the trump supporters
what is this do you know uh it's last
three months okay yeah i mean that this
that's so sad and it unfortunately
reinforces the point that i was trying
to make which is that even
even this this book that was written two
years ago well that was published two
years ago and written
you know two years and one and two years
before that
which was pointing out how dire a
situation we are in and was able to find
a couple of examples
of of good of good faith and openness
even those doors are closing right and
that we we just we are not
seeing anything of the kind of openness
and generosity of spirit
or um imagining that other people have
intentions
and honorability just like you do
that we were even a couple of years ago
so
i think the thing that i'm getting out
of it
even in a very polarized environment
there are still things
on which you might agree
right in other words there are things
that are simply good for the nation
and we can be divided about a lot of
stuff but we should agree obviously on
the stuff that's good for all of us why
wouldn't we it'd be insane not to and it
would be crazy if there was nothing in
that category but
our style of interaction has now
produced
an assumption that if it's good for you
it's bad for me right
this can't help but be a disaster and
what it means
is that we are botching the stuff
that should be within our grasp right if
everybody feels good
when they watch a blm guy and a trump
guy
have a positive interaction in which
they come to agreement about the fact
that all lives are valuable
right if that makes people feel good you
would imagine there'd be a lot of it
because
it would be a you know but what
happens is one gets demonized
for it so if you have poles that are
serving their own interests
selfish poles that don't want us to find
common ground because it is not in their
interest that we do so
what they will do is they will demonize
you when you seek it i must say this is
in the unity 2020 context
i have seen a huge outpouring of
patriotism and decency amongst people
who have gravitated to it
but i have also seen the most amazing
emergence of this bitter toxic
cynical despicable voice right
where people uh i mean look you can
disagree with unity 2020 if you want
right
you could say well you know it's too
late you could say
i don't believe that your anti-spoiler
uh
measures are actually going to work uh
so you know we have to reject it
but the thing that has come back at me
has been
the accusation that it is not a good
faith proposal that i am actually
up to something that i'm working for
somebody or that i'm trying to
accomplish something greedy or something
like that
and it's a shocking thing but if you
if you take out the content of that
accuracy
it's always the first thing that shows
up though isn't it i mean
we saw we we've seen this and we've
heard from other friends who've gone
through the looking glass that that is
one of the first
if if you emerge and you're standing if
you have a movement that appears to be
that has some traction and has some
support the things that start getting
lobbed at you
are you're working for koch brothers
right you're you know you're part of the
fox news network
you aren't what you say you are you're
grifting you know all of these things
will show up
you're serving your own interests yeah
right so
i find this shocking though i mean on
the one hand i think it
basically you know if you take our motif
of you're very
often better off turning down the sound
on human interactions because you'll
understand better what's going on
in this case you can't really turn down
the sound but you can turn down
your focus on the uh actual content of
the accusations and you can say
when a party sees its interest
in division right when it doesn't want
unity
what will it do right it will drive up
the costs of
anything that tries to find common
ground right
and so the point is when you see
something seeking common ground and then
you see it taking fire
from outside this is simply what it is
somebody doesn't want that middle ground
discovered
right they don't want the 70
of americans that the hidden tribes
report identifies as the exhausted
middle
that basically agrees on what direction
the country should go
doesn't want that thing to unify it
needs it divided and so
that um the punishing of
the honorable middle is just so
despicable
and we should just we should name it
somehow
and then just learn to recognize it
because it's going to happen every time
and since the only way out of this
pickle
is finding some path in which we can do
what hawk newsom
uh did in that interaction where we can
cross bridges and find the humanity in
in our fellow americans or fellow
portlanders or whatever
if that's what has to happen then we've
got to be able to resist the accusations
that come back at you when you attempt
it
[Music]